ja guten morgen hier aus berlin
tatsächlich auch hier wird es zu beginn
dieser bundestagssitzung einleitende
worte zum gedenken an die queen geben
von bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
auch ist überall auf dem reichstag auch
auf anderen regierungsgebäuden auch auf
den botschaften beispielsweise halbmast
geflaggt hier in berlin auch gestern gab
es übrigens als die nachricht des todes
über die ticker lief hier im bundestag
da saß man noch zusammen sind ja wir
sind ja mitten in den
haushaltsberatungen da wurde die sitzung
kurz unterbrochen und es gab tatsächlich
auch eine gedenk minute also auch hier
auch wenn man mitten in den
haushaltsberatungen steckt spielt es
durchaus zumindest eine kleine rolle
aber wir sind sozusagen am letzten und
vierten tag der haushaltsberatung rund
30 stunden haben die abgeordneten
haushaltsberatungen hier in dieser woche
schon absolviert heute steht noch mal
die schlussrunde hier des
haushaltsplanes an und der einzelplan
innen wird heute nochmal debattiert
diese haushaltsberatung die standen ganz
im zeichen des angriffskrieges russlands
auf die ukraine die standen im zeichen
der energiekrise der inflation und die
stand auch im zeichen der sorgen der
menschen ob sie sich künftig ihren
alltag überhaupt noch leisten können die
opposition die hat in dieser woche
ausgiebig den haushaltsplan kritisiert
aber auch das dritte entlastungs paket
der bundesregierung und noch mehr die
linke und die afg die wollen im herbst
zu protesten aufrufen gegen die
energiepolitik gegen die sozialpolitik
der bundesregierung und kündigen
wortgleich einen heißen herbst auf den
straßen an in den letzten wochen haben
sicherheitsbehörden gewarnt dass
proteste friedliche proteste
unterwandert werden könnten von
extremisten und dass diese gewalt sogar
das sogar gewalt eskalieren könnte
deswegen wollen wir heute morgen nicht
nur auf den einzelplan innen schauen wer
jetzt hier gleich debattiert wird
sondern auch auf dieses thema proteste
und ich darf zwei gäste dazu herzlich
begrüßen zwar innenpolitiker ihrer
fraktionen nicht fertig begrüßen
sebastian fiedler für die spd-fraktion
mit dem innenausschuss auch sprecher für
kriminalpolitik der spd-fraktion und
bernd baumann darf ich begrüßen den
ersten parlamentarischen geschäftsführer
der fdp fraktion ebenfalls mitglied im
innenausschuss
herr baumann ihre fraktionsvorsitzende
alice weil hat in der generaldebatte in
dieser woche in richtung bundesregierung
gedroht sie müssen zitat sie haben allen
grund einen heißen herbst und winter zu
fürchten wenn die kfd unter diesem motto
zu protesten aufruft welche art von
protest muss man sich unter diesem
begriff heißer herbst vorstellen es ist
ja vieles was im haushalt jetzt im argen
liegt dass man ansprechen muss wir haben
jetzt inneres das thema gerade da wird
die bundespolizei kaputtgespart nach
soll vorgaben planvorgaben sind 400
millionen weniger als im vorjahr das
kann nicht sein der präsident der
bundespolizei spricht dass die
einsatzbereitschaft bedroht ist die
gewerkschaft die bundespolizei spricht
von der katastrophe insgesamt hat die
bevölkerung natürlich alles recht zu
demonstrieren weil grundlegende
politikbereiche die afg hat immer davor
gewarnt einfach da niederlegen wenn man
sich nur mal anguckt die währung euro
inflationsraten wir jetzt die afd war
die partei die davor gewarnt hat
deswegen haben wir uns gegründet weil
der euro falsch aufgestellt ist jetzt
haben der entsetzliche inflationsraten
der euro wird soll ihrer natürlich geht
das volk da auf die straße
da schmelzen die ersparnisse zusammen
gleich in der energiepolitik dass das
nicht geht die afg hat gewarnt man kann
nicht gleichzeitig aussteigen aus
braunkohle steinkohle atomkraft kein
land der welt macht das jetzt
explodieren die preise nicht nur wegen
putin sondern wegen dieser falschen
politik haben wir auch die abhängigkeit
vom russischen gas das waren die
kabinette merkel und jetzt scholz die
nehmen alle ihr recht in die hand jetzt
auf die straße zu geben wann wenn ich
jetzt bei solche schieflage wir müssen
nicht darüber sprechen dass natürlich
bürger auf die straße gehen
demonstrationsrecht ist im grundgesetz
verankert natürlich ich wollte mehr
daraufhin aus welchen ton die afg
anschlägt weil sie durchaus ja auf
konfrontation gehen und diese proteste
die muss man sich dann gut anschauen
ihre fraktionsvorsitzende weiter hat
gestern als sie ihre kampagne und eine
kundgebung angekündigt haben für anfang
oktober beispielsweise gesagt
deutschland werde absolut für arm und
die menschen würden teilweise ihre jobs
verlieren also mobilisieren sie hier
durch ängste heizen sie diese protest
sicher durch ängste bewusst an die
befüllt hat doch entsetzliche ängste da
gibt es doch jeden grund dazu wenn sie
sehen wie viel wir haben jetzt schon
pleite gemacht haben weil sie die
energiekosten nicht tragen können das
geht von kleinen mittelständischen
unternehmen und klein einzelunternehmern
bis hin zu großen unternehmen wie hakel
und so was wir gehört haben in hamburg
werden produktion eingestellt von großen
firmen das ist da kommt was
entsetzliches auf uns zu die leute haben
die rechnungen ja noch gar nicht in der
tasche die haben jetzt eine ahnung dass
alles teurer wird wenn sie das erst mal
haben 60 prozent haben ja keine
ersparnisse das wird eine entsetzliche
situation werden oder gehen die leute
auf die straße die afg vertritt ihre
themen wie sie immer hatte das sind
genau die gleichen themen wie die der
bevölkerung und haben kann die
innenministerin nicht sagen da kommen
jetzt rechtsradikale und diese
demonstration werden dich gerechtfertigt
oder in delegitimiert da ist das falsche
demokratie will ich auch nicht ich habe
ja ich habe ja sozusagen auch gefragt
nach ihrer kundgebung herr fiedler
bundeskanzler olaf scholz sagt er
rechnet nicht mit unruhen mit sozialen
unruhen im herbst hat auch darauf
hingewiesen es gibt das dritte
entlastungspaket trotzdem am montag
haben menschen bereits in leipziger in
magdeburg demonstriert auch gegen die
energiepolitik der bundesregierung etwas
rechnen sie
wenn sie gestatten es einsatz schon noch
dazu sagen die afg spricht nicht für die
bevölkerung sowie das gerade so
suggeriert wird sondern es gibt einen
unterschied der politischen kräfte das
muss man vielleicht erklären dass auch
ein großer erklärung sozusagen für ihre
frage es gibt eben die politischen
parteien zu denen ich die hälfte jetzt
nicht rechnet die sozusagen darum bemüht
sind den gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt
in dieser schwierigen situation
krisensituation zu stärken die alle
politischen bemühungen darauf stützen
und die ard versucht immer den spaltpilz
in der gesellschaft zu identifizieren
und ihre themen danach auszurichten wie
sie diesen spaltpilz immer tief
vertreiben kann und das ist sozusagen
der grund für die beteiligung jetzt an
diesen protesten das herbeireden von
immer noch schlimmeren
untergangsszenarien das sind die großen
unterschiede so und womit wir rechnen
ist natürlich dass es keine neue
situation die sicherheitsbehörden sagen
dass schon lange es hat sich mindestens
in den anti corona protesten gezeigt
dass wir einen neuen extremismus sehen
ich nenne den verein wort verschwörungs
extremismus und wir erkennen ja dass
dieselben leute die sich gegen die
korona maßnahmen gestimmt haben
dieselben die putin fans jetzt gebaut
sind in den entsprechenden kanälen das
sind dieselben die jetzt bei
untergangsszenarien waren und es werden
auch dieselben sein die irgendwann vor
einer sogenannten klima diktatur waren
das habe schon damals gesagt dieser
extremismus bleiben uns erhalten und die
afg springt hier drauf natürlich und
versucht möglichst anzuheizen die
vokabel heißer herbst bedeutet ja sie
ist nicht etwa bemüht den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt zu
stärken sondern wir sollten schon genau
darauf schauen welche politischen kräfte
versuchen den noch zu verstärken und
noch anzuheizen während wir hier glaube
ich mit dem bild besser bedient sind
denn die sind als bunten der
bundeskanzler immer versucht
unterzubringen wir müssen uns unterhaken
wert und wir müssen sehen wie wir durch
diese zeit kommen und ich glaube man
kann wirklich sagen die bundesregierung
hat wirklich alles getan mit großen
unterstützungsmaßnahmen für wirtschaft
und bevölkerung dass das auch gelingen
kann trotzdem muss man fragen wie soll
denn der bürger der auf die straße geht
der demonstriert im herbst unterscheiden
können ihre innenministerin hat gesagt
ja die demonstranten müssten sich
sozusagen
distanzieren von extremisten aber
selbstverständlich also wie soll das
entscheiden können also es wird dazu
demonstration angemeldet und ich würde
nicht im leben auf die idee kommen wenn
die freien sachsen oder die afg eine
demonstration anmeldet mich da in diese
demonstration zu begeben also da muss
ich schon unterscheiden es gibt eben
parteien die stehen im
verfassungsschutzbericht aus guten
gründen weil sie antidemokratisch
unterwegs sind und es gibt eben solche
die zum demokratischen spektrum gehören
die sich um den zusammenhalt der
gesellschaft bemühen die sorgen ernst
nehmen wollen und da gibt's natürlich
ein legitimes interesse zu demonstrieren
es geht darum wo wird angeheizt und die
ried das risiko erhöht dass es zu
gewalttaten kommt und da unterscheiden
sich die parteien sehr
sie werden auch sozusagen seit' an seit'
auch mit der linken ja diese
demonstration anmelden und hat im
gleichen begriff michael heißer herbst
sie muss man sich das vorstellen
zunächst machen war zum vorredner also
dass da jetzt rechts und rechtsradikale
unterwegs sind das mag sein an der einen
oder anderen stelle das muss bekämpft
werden aber die demonstrations- gründe
die
inflation wie sie die
inflation die ganze energie politik dass
die dass die innenminister ihre ihre
verfassungsschutzämter missbrauchen die
ihm unterstellt sind das ist klar die
grünen legen die menschen rest der
bevölkerung ist legitim er versucht
jetzt auch jeder dass zu delegitimieren
dass die bevölkerung wird demonstrieren
aus google recht von den ideen die
diskussion noch weiterführen an anderer
stelle ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich
dass wir heute morgen da waren und ich
gebe rhein zu bärbel bas in den saal